how many people here would like to live
to be at least 80 years old yeah I think
we all have this hopeful expectation of
living into old age
let's project out into the future to
your future use and let's imagine that
we're all 85 now everyone look at two
people one of you probably has
Alzheimer's disease alright and maybe
you're thinking well it won't be me then
okay you are a caregiver so in some way
this terrifying disease is likely to
affect us all part of the sphere around
Alzheimer's stems from the sense that
there's nothing we can do about it
despite decades of research we still
have no disease modifying treatment and
no cure so if we're lucky enough to live
long enough
Alzheimer's appears to be our brains
destiny but maybe it doesn't have to be
what if I told you we could change these
statistics literally change our brains
destiny without relying on a cure our
advancements in medicine let's begin by
looking at what we currently understand
about the neuroscience of Alzheimer's
here's a picture of two neurons
connecting the point of connection the
space circled in red is called the
synapse the synapse is where
neurotransmitters are released this is
where signals are transmitted where
communication happens this is where we
think feel see here desire and remember
and the synapse is where Alzheimer's
happens let's zoom in on the synapse and
look at a cartoon representation of
what's going on during the business of
communicating information in a dish
- releasing neurotransmitters like
glutamate into the synapse neurons also
release a small peptide called amyloid
beta normally amyloid beta is cleared
away and metabolized by microglia the
janitor cells of our brains while the
molecular causes of Alzheimer's are
still debated most neuroscientists
believe that the disease begins when
amyloid beta begins to accumulate too
much is released or not enough is
cleared away and the synapse begins to
pile up with amyloid beta and when this
happens it binds to itself forming
sticky add Rockets called amyloid
plaques how many people here are 40
years old or older you're afraid to
admit it now this initial step into the
disease this presence of amyloid plaques
accumulating can already be found in
your brains now the only way we could be
sure of this would be through a PET scan
because at this point you are blissfully
unaware you're not showing any
impairments in memory language or
cognition yes we think it takes at least
15 to 20 years of amyloid plaque
accumulation before it reaches a tipping
point then triggering a molecular
cascade that causes the clinical
symptoms of the disease prior to the
tipping point your lapses in memory
might include things like why did I come
in this room or Oh what's his name or
where did I put my keys yeah now before
you all start freaking out again because
I know half of you did at least one of
those in the last 24 hours
these are all normal kinds of forgetting
in fact I would argue that these
examples might not even involve your
memory because you didn't pay attention
to where you put your keys in the first
place after the tipping point the
glitches in memory language and
cognition are different
instead of eventually finding your keys
in your coat pocket on the table by the
door you find them in the refrigerator
or you find them and you think what are
these for okay so what happens when
amyloid plaques
accumulates this tipping point our
microglia janitor cells become hyper
activated releasing chemicals that cause
inflammation and cellular damage we
think they might actually start clearing
away the synapses themselves a crucial
neural transport protein called tau
becomes hyper phosphorylated and twists
itself into something called tangles
which choke off the neurons from the
inside by mid-stage Alzheimer's we have
massive inflammation and tangles and
all-out war at the synapse and cell
death so if you are a scientist trying
to cure this disease at what point would
you ideally want to intervene many
scientists are betting big on the
simplest solution keep amyloid plaques
from reaching that tipping point which
means that drug discovery is largely
focused on developing a compound that
will prevent eliminate or reduce amyloid
plaque accumulation and so the cure for
Alzheimer's will likely be a preventive
medicine we're going to have to take
this pill before we reach that tipping
point before the cascade is triggered
before we start leaving our keys in the
refrigerator we think this is why to
date these kinds of drugs have failed in
clinical trials not because the science
wasn't found but because the people in
these Charles were already symptomatic
it was too late
think of amyloid plaques as a lit match
at the tipping point the match sets fire
to the forest
once the forest is ablaze it doesn't do
any good to blow at the match you have
to blow at the match before the force
catches fire even before scientists sort
this out this information is actually
really good news for us because it turns
out that the way we live can influence
the accumulation of amyloid plaques and
so there are things we can do to keep us
from reaching that tipping point let's
picture your risk of Alzheimer's as a
seesaw scale we're going to pile risk
factors on one arm and when that arm
hits the floor you are symptomatic and
diagnosed with Alzheimer's let's imagine
you're 50 years old you're not a spring
chicken anymore so you've accumulated
some amyloid
with age your scale is tipped a little
bit now let's look at your DNA we've all
inherited our genes from our moms and
our dads some of these genes will
increase our risk and some will decrease
it if you're like Alice and still Alice
you've inherited a rare genetic mutation
that cranks out amyloid data and this
alone will tip your scale arm to the
ground but for most of us the genes we
inherit will only tip the arm a bit
for example a bowi 4 is a gene variant
that increases amyloid but you can
inherit a copy of apoe4 from mom and dad
and still never get Alzheimer's which
means that for most of us our DNA alone
does not determine whether we get
Alzheimer's so what does we can't do
anything about getting older or the
genes we've inherited so far we haven't
changed our brains destiny what about
sleep in slow waves deep sleep our glial
cells rinsed cerebral spinal fluid
through our brains clearing away
metabolic wastes that accumulated in our
synapses while we were awake deep sleep
is like a power cleanse for the brain
but what happens if you shortchange
yourself on sleep many scientists
believe that poor sleep hygiene might
actually be a predictor of Alzheimer's a
single night of sleep deprivation leads
to an increase in amyloid beta and
amyloid accumulation has been shown to
disrupt sleep which in turn causes more
amyloid to accumulate and so now we have
this positive feedback loop that's going
to accelerate the tipping of that scale
what else
cardiovascular health high blood
pressure diabetes obesity smoking high
cholesterol has all been shown to
increase our risk of developing
Alzheimer's some autopsy studies have
shown that as many as 80% of people with
Alzheimer's also had cardiovascular
disease aerobic exercise have been shown
in many studies to decrease amyloid beta
and animal models of the disease so a
heart-healthy Mediterranean lifestyle
and diet can help to counter the tipping
of the scale okay so there are many
we can do to prevent or delay the onset
of Alzheimer's but let's say you haven't
done any of them let's say you're 65
there's Alzheimer's in your family so
you've likely inherited a gene or two
that tips your scale I'm a bit you've
been burning the candle at both ends for
years you love bacon and you don't run
unless someone's chasing you let's
imagine that your amyloid plaques have
reached that tipping point your scale
arm has crashed to the floor you've
tripped the cascade setting fire to the
forest causing inflammation tangles and
cell death you should be symptomatic for
Alzheimer's you should be having trouble
finding words and keys and remembering
what I said at the beginning of this
talk but you might not be there's one
more thing you can do to protect
yourself from experiencing the symptoms
of Alzheimer's even if you have the
full-blown disease pathology ablaze in
your brain it has to do with neural
plasticity and cognitive reserve
remember the experience of having
Alzheimer's is ultimately a result of
losing synapses the average brain has
over a hundred trillion synapses which
is fantastic we've got a lot to work
with and this isn't a static number we
gain and lose synapses all the time
through a process called neural
plasticity every time we learn something
new we are creating and strengthening
new neural connections new synapses in
the nun study six hundred and seventy
eight nuns all over the age of 75 when
the study began were followed for more
than two decades they were regularly
given physical checkups and cognitive
tests and when they died their brains
were all donated for autopsies in some
of these brains scientists discovered
something surprising despite the
presence of plaques and tangles and
brain shrinkage would appear to be
unquestionable Alzheimer's the months
would belong to these brains showed no
signs of having the disease while they
were alive how can this be we think it's
because these nuns had a high level of
cognitive reserve which is a way of
saying that they had more functional
and asses people who have more years of
formal education who have a high degree
of literacy who engage regularly and
mentally stimulating activities all have
more cognitive reserve they have an
abundance and a redundancy and neural
connections so even if they have a
disease like Alzheimer's compromising
some of their synapses they've got many
extra backup connections and this
buffers them from noticing that anything
is amiss let's imagine a simplified
example let's say you only know one
thing about a subject let's say it's
about me you know that Lisa Genova wrote
still Alice and that's the only thing
you know about me you have that single
neural connection that one synapse
while imagine you have Alzheimer's you
have plaques and tangles and
inflammation and microglia devouring
that synapse now when someone asks you
hey who won't still Alice you can't
remember because that synapse is either
failing or gone you've forgotten me
forever but what if you have learned
more about me let's say you learn four
things about me now imagine you have
Alzheimer's and three of those synapses
that are damaged or destroyed you still
have a way to detour the wreckage you
can still remember my name so we can be
resilient to the presence of Alzheimer's
pathology through the recruitment of yet
undamaged pathways and we create these
pathways this cognitive reserve learning
new things now ideally we want these new
things to be as rich in meaning as
possible
recruiting sight and sound and
associations and emotion so this really
doesn't mean doing crossword puzzles you
don't want to simply retrieve
information you've already learned
because this is like traveling down old
familiar streets cruising neighborhoods
you already know you want to pave new
neural roads building and Alzheimer's
resistant brain means learning to speak
Italian meeting new friends reading a
book or listening to a great TED talk
and if despite all of this you are
someday diagnosed with Alzheimer's
there are three lessons I've learned
from my grandmother and the dozens of
people have come to know living with
this disease diagnosis doesn't mean
you're dying tomorrow keep living you
won't lose your emotional memory you'll
still be able to understand love and joy
you might not remember what I said five
minutes ago but you'll remember how I
made you feel and you are more than what
you can remember thank you
[Applause]